hey what is up everybody it's annamac
here for
anime uproar and today i will be talking
about
all the latest developments in the black
clover story
including the crazy new magic powers
and transformations that have recently
been introduced
i will also be talking about how the
epic final showdown against the dark
triad
is going so far and how the new massive
power ups that we have been introduced
to
are going to end up being total game
changers in
this battle finally i will explain why
this is just the beginning
of the fight with the dark triad and why
i think that the zogratis siblings still
have a lot more demonic
tricks up their sleeves so let's get
into it if you enjoy our black clover
videos and you want us to keep it going
do me a favor
and leave a like and if you're new to
the channel or maybe you just haven't
subscribed yet
make this the video do subscribe and hit
that
notification bell to turn on all
notifications
you gotta go through the trouble of
hitting that bell and then selecting the
option that says all
i know it's annoying it's an extra step
but if you don't do that you're still
gonna miss a ton of our videos even if
you are subscribed
it's just how youtube works finally this
video will of course contain black
clover manga spoilers
so please proceed with caution you have
been warned now to start things off just
a quick word about the previous chapter
the one where charlotte unlocked her
true briar magic
when that chapter came out i was
actually busy with a bunch of family
stuff over the holidays and so i
couldn't make a special video
on that chapter but to be brief we saw a
continuation of the xenon versus yuno
and langris fight and we saw that xenon
appeared to be
seriously injured and yuno and langris
seem to have the upper hand at least for
now
the focus of the chapter then quickly
shifted to the fight between vanica on
the one side
and charlotte and rill on the other at
first
vanica wasn't impressed with real and
charlotte because she was looking
forward to fighting noel
or at least a star yami however during
the fight against vanica
charlotte revealed that she learned to
use the heart kingdom's rune magic
during the time skip with the help of
rune magic she was able to modify the
curse that was placed on her and turn it
into a special
anti-curse spell and this was something
that surprised
even megikula the master of all
curses but more than that charlotte was
finally able to unlock her
true magic along with her trademark blue
roses
she is also able to manifest red roses
which are produced when she
uses true briar magic this magic seems
to have the power to turn megicula's own
power against her
and after attaining a new queen of
briar's form
charlotte also appeared to gain the
upper hand against humanik and megikula
by trapping them inside her true briar
magic
so at this point everything is looking
pretty good for the clover kingdom magic
knights
both in the fight against xenon and in
the fight against
vanica that said though you just know
that things are about to get turned
upside down very soon since there's no
way that the dark triad will be defeated
so easily
but before that happens we get to see
the fight against the third member of
the dark triad
dante in the latest installment of the
story we get to see knock and jack
taking on dante but first damn tabata
that cover page vanica is getting the
medal
on a birthday suit treatment from a few
chapters ago
and i am not complaining oh and yeah i
guess dante and xena were on the cover
too but who cares about them
as the chapter begins we jump right into
the third
big fight despite jack's fierce slashing
attacks
dante is able to instantly regenerate
without any problems
and dante actually comments that thanks
to morris's magical science
his regeneration ability has gotten even
stronger
dante is convinced that osta's
anti-magic is the only thing that could
possibly hurt him
in any way however noct and jack
believe that even without asta there is
another way
and that other way is jack's slash
magic which theoretically has the
potential to slash through
anything even that which is considered
uncutable
presumably this means that jack's
slashing magic
could potentially find a way to damage
dante
but dante isn't really interested in
wasting his time with noct and jack
so he launches his gravity magic spell
called presence of the demon
king both jack and noct are pulled down
to the ground
by the gravity magic but noct is able to
break free using one of his devils
by using his devil unite form with this
devil he attains a new
armored form whose main attribute is
strength
dante is surprised that along with asta
there are other devil magic users among
the clover kingdom mages
and a bitter fight ensues to knox credit
he is able to exchange a few blows with
dante
but knock knows that he won't be able to
finish dante off
he simply cannot defeat such a powerful
devil magic user on his own
noct must get jack to use his slash
magic
against dante but in that moment
jack is still pinned to the ground by
dante's gravity magic
and he doesn't seem capable of breaking
free as noct
tries to encourage jack to overcome the
gravity magic and yes
let's call it encourage we actually get
a bit of jack's
backstory it turns out that his father
was a commoner and a hunter
and he was a careful and conservative
man who made it a point to never get
into a fight that he couldn't win
as a result he only hunted small animals
and he did his best to avoid danger but
then one day while he was out on a hunt
jack's dad was killed by a giant bear
jack ended up tracking the bear down and
killing him
and that's when he realized that he had
the potential to do more
with his life he didn't have to go
through life being extremely cautious
and conservative like his father
it didn't work out so well for his
father anyway and so
jack could use his powerful slash magic
to do
bigger and better things like joining
the magic
knights and so that was the beginning of
jack's journey from a commoner who lost
his father at a young age to a magic
knight captain back on the battlefield
jack is able to pull it together
and he seems to unlock a new aspect to
his slash
magic he unleashes a barrage of slashing
attacks that are actually able to cut
through dante's gravity magic and he
then unlocks a new praying mantis form
that allows him to grow powerful blades
all over his body
jack unleashes a storm of slashes
directly at dante
and it appears that the slashes are
actually doing some damage
as dante looks both surprised and
concerned
at jack's newfound magical ability even
knocked admits that jack was being
underestimated
and that is how this chapter ends
it appears that the clover kingdom magic
knights have gotten the upper hand
in battle yet again and so at this point
all three members of the dark triad
xenon vanika
and dante are losing the fight against
their designated opponents from the
clover kingdom
however we must not forget that this is
only the beginning of the big battle
against the dark
triad yes we saw you know charlotte and
jack
unlocking new forms and new magical
abilities
and it is clear that the clover kingdom
mages have really leveled up
the three of them have already
demonstrated impressive power-ups and so
have mere leona and langris and the
others
and i'm sure that noct has plenty of
tricks up his sleeve and we still don't
know the true extent of his power
personally i'm especially interested in
jack's new power
because the ability to potentially cut
through any magic
is no joke it's not quite the same as
austa's anti-magic
but it could have some similar effects
once the full potential of this ability
is unlocked but with all of that being
said this battle against the dark triad
is just getting started i am sure that
the tables will be turned many times
before this epic showdown is over and in
the very next chapter we may see one
or more of the members of the dark triad
pushing back against their opponents
and regaining the higher ground these
new forms and powers that the magic
knights have achieved are definitely
major improvements and they are game
changing in many ways
but we have to remember that we still
haven't seen the full extent of the dark
triads power and now thanks to morris
and his science
it looks like dante is even stronger
than he was when he fought yami and asta
so even though the story is leading us
to believe that the clover kingdom magic
knights are currently winning all three
fights
i'm sure that the tables are about to be
turned on them very soon
maybe in the very next chapter so what
do you guys think about all of these new
forms and powers that the magic knights
have unlocked including
yuno charlotte and jack also what do you
think about
knocked armored form and what other
powers and abilities
is he hiding what do you expect to see
from his other devils
as this fight continues finally what do
you expect to see from the dark
triad are they about to go ham and flip
the script
on everyone will someone be seriously
injured or even killed
during this battle before osta makes his
grand
entrance definitely share your thoughts
down in the comments below
if you enjoyed this video and you want
to see more black lover content here on
the channel you know what to do
leave a like to let me know it really
does help
and if you're new to the channel or
maybe you just haven't subscribed yet
make this the video that you subscribe
and hit that notification bell
to turn on all notifications you can
also hit me up on twitter
and instagram at anime uproar
a big thank you to all of our anime
uproar patrons for making videos like
this one possible
special thank you to alpha sigma a
disciple of lord twigo
himself and i can't forget all of our
the one
tier patrons the ones who rise above all
other clans
including ingrata the world acquired
respect
pate hepha rathee and yx emperor otaku
spidey life canal
big buddhist and tungsten tarkis finally
thank you to all of our pro hero tier
patrons including the one and only
gilgamesh steelers angel cruz anatoly
kazatsky
joe stanton barry gucci jessica kayla
fond rathune de ora
alicia octor bonnie parks you know comey
and water the red-haired raymond florian
joanne garcia jack watches anime fat boy
games
deadly saint matthew cruz anthony
schreiber hi jinx and mr waffles 247.
if you enjoy our videos and you feel
that they provide value for you consider
supporting us
on patreon even a single dollar will
give you access to our patron exclusive
discord
and your name will appear in our videos
along with these amazing people
as always thank you guys so much for
watching and until next time
see ya space cowboys
[Music]
you